oh i kicked some ass
in court documents obtained by e.t
scarlett claims she lost more than 50
million dollars because
disney released black widow on its
streaming service and in theaters
at the same time her suit alleges that
her salary was tied
to what it would have made at the box
office if this case goes on you're going
to see a lot of dirty laundry aired on
both sides
wall street journal reporter joe flint
broke the story he told us public
battles like this are rare
most of the time these feuds are settled
behind closed doors
in this case scarlett has fired a shot
across disney's bow
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
she feels that her contract should have
been renegotiated when disney made the
move to put the movie on disney plus
disney's response was blunt disney went
scorched earth on birth
the company said scarlett's lawsuit has
no merit and they went on to call it sad
and distressing in its callous disregard
for the pandemic
and disney went so far as to even put
how much money she's made on the movie
to date which is around 20 million
dollars this morning
scarlett johansson's agent put out a
very
strong statement criticizing disney for
releasing her salary so did streaming
really cost scarjo
50 million well consider this like
scarlet sandra bullock is said to have
been paid 20 million dollars to star in
gravity
the profits from the film reportedly led
to her getting an additional
50 million bringing her total to 70
million dollars
i have a bad feeling about this mission
and iron man robert downey jr had a
similar back end deal he reportedly made
75 million total on avengers end game
iron man it remains to be seen how this
will affect audiences but
another factor scarlett's a trailblazer
in the franchise
are you officially like the first
avenger
slash producer of the bunch on their of
their own standalone film
yes come on come on that actually
in many ways was my greatest
accomplishment
on this film was being able to executive
produce it
movie stars have agents and lawyers for
the heavy lifting
and the dirty work and this is a
contract dispute plain and simple
[Music]